a 5 000 year old mode of transport
is slowly disappearing from iraq's
unesco heritage marshes
sabiha remembers that six decades ago
there was water in the ahwar or
marshes it's been four or five years and
the water level is decreasing gradually
it really affects us when there's water
the marshes come to life and we can fish
when i was young the marshes were a
magnificent place not like these days we
were able to collect marsh reeds and
fish now we're left with nothing
as the water dries up so does the demand
to make the ancient mushuf or marsh boat
in addition to boat making there used to
be work for maintenance and upkeep
now most of the boat makers have left
the swamps and rivers in southern kufa
basra and
many of the 20 types of boats for
hunting transport or passengers are not
being made anymore
the ones which are made use imported
materials
the ancient technique of making the
mushuf or the marsh boat is all but lost
the local wood has been replaced by
industrial timber the arches are now
being made with java wood and instead of
whale oil they're using fiberglass and
chemical tar
in addition to climate change and drying
marshes boat makers also face frequent
power cuts
fadal is a third generation boat builder
and says it's quicker using modern
equipment and imported materials are
cheap
the old boat was made of wood cotton and
nails now all these materials are not
used now fibreglass is used it's better
than the old way previously people
waited for a month to get a boat but
with low water level there's no work my
biggest fear is the drought no water
means no work for us
one of the world's largest inland delta
has shrunk from 9 000 to just under 800
square kilometers
the marshes were dried for oil
production and agriculture from the
1970s then to combat armed groups in the
1990s
and people from the marshes say the
promises to help have just been quote
ink on paper
the government did not do anything for
the marshes no strategic plans no health
or educational projects the residents
are deprived of everything the boat
industry flourished once but now the
marshes are getting smaller and people
rely on fewer boats climate change is
the main factor it will become worse
with summer evaporation levels also
upstream dams in turkey and iran mean
more than 40 river tributaries are
totally cut off
the water buffaloes are an important
part of the local dairy industry but
human and animal waste is also a
challenge for the fragile ecology
boat making in this pristine habitat and
its ancient heritage are all at risk
and without immediate action
this unique marshland is pushed closer
to extinction every day
osama bin laden
of southern iraq